nous avoir débarqué à la gare de Lyon
quand j'ai vu tous ces visages tristes
blême fatigué
je me suis dit
il faut des sourires
[Musique]
je m'appelle François menantaux et je
viens de Toulon on va je suis venu à
Paris pour chanter
moi je suis parisienne
je m'appelle Chantal Laurency et je
chante au cabaret depuis environ
6 ans presque 6 ans
je suis venu au cabaret à
de façon assez normale il faut bien le
dire par le théâtre j'ai commencé
d'abord par suivre des cours d'art
dramatiques
et là je me suis fait extrêmement mal
voir parce que j'avais une mauvaise voix
mauvais
[Musique]
je suis décidé il y a trois mois de
venir à Paris enfin après un an et demi
[Musique]
c'est assez dur au début
très impressionné d'abord va
falloir rythme de la vie les gens sont
tous pressés et évidemment la première
semaine j'ai eu du mal à m'adapter à
[Musique]
ce rythme quand je parle
les gens sont noyés à Paris que nos
vacances c'est normal
je dois dire que les débuts sont très
pénibles pour un chanteur pour un gars
qui qui espère pouvoir chanter quelque
part qui espère pouvoir gagner sa vie en
chantant je crois que c'est très dur au
début
tout seul il faut aller voir les gens et
provoquer
se montrer chercher vous aider non
personne ne vous aide au départ il faut
vraiment il faut vraiment se débrouiller
seul au départ surtout au départ par la
suite donc vous êtes bien entendu quand
on commence à vous connaître des gens
viendront des gens vous proposeront du
travail ou les choses intéressantes mais
vraiment quand on démarre je suis à
Paris
j'ai trouvé les gens très très gentils
qui m'ont aidé
qui m'ont permis de qui m'ont donné
beaucoup d'espoir
et de ce fait je reste parce que
ces gens je me rends compte
espère en moi crois en moi
la longueur et la durée de l'expérience
parce que on est très souvent tenté de
se décourager dans ce métier
cela fait deux ans que je chante
je m'accorde encore deux ans
que pour gagner sa vie en chantant c'est
vraiment trop trop difficile il faut
avoir un job derrière soi il faut
travailler sinon on s'en sort pas
imaginez-vous que dans un cabaret de
l'odeur rive gauche vous paie 20 francs
puis dans les conditions qui sont très
dures il faut attendre il faut patienter
il faut demander des auditions au patron
cela n'est pas facile les forfaits on me
dit ah bon on met on ne peut pas vous
recevoir mais si mais si mais si et je
vais à faire des tas de situations
c'est en général d'abord assez
désagréable parce que on n'a pas un
public ordinaire on a publié critique
quelquefois gentil dans la mesure où les
gens qui vous font passer les auditions
se mettent à votre place j'avais appris
par un mes camarades qu'on avait qui
avait des auditions pour une pour une
pièce
comique chanter et il me conseille de
m'y rendre tant qu'il y avait encore des
producteurs et des directeurs
artistiques suivaient et je prends le
couloir des audition le couloir des
artistes et puis je suis scoloir comme
ça au pif plutôt à l'oreille d'ailleurs
à l'oreille parce que j'entendais de
très loin j'entendais un piano alors
j'avançais dans la direction du piano
j'avançais j'avançais jusqu'au moment où
je me suis retrouvée sur la scène sur la
scène un théâtre qui me semble à peu
près vide et
dans la pénombre j'ai aperçu une ombre
qui m'était
familière et qui m'a dit alors
mademoiselle ce que vous désirez
je me suis retrouvé devant le directeur
pour producteur et tout ce qu'on fait et
tout ce qu'on veut dans la pièce en
question
[Musique]
la première chanson sur Paris s'intitule
Le provincial j'ai composé cette chanson
immédiatement
après avoir débarqué à la gare de Lyon
quand j'ai vu tous ces visages tristes
blême fatigué
je me suis dit
il faut des sourires et des sourires
avec des gens bien
on a besoin de ça quand on arrive dans
une nuit nouvelle qu'on ne connaît pas
[Musique]
il y a que des souris rien que le matin
je veux rien que des sourires rien que
des gens bien
qu'un peu de place un tout petit peu
d'espace je veux passer chemin sans
gêner le coin
où je viens de loin briser ma solitude
trouver les habitudes trouver l'amour
rien qu'un des partement le vent et la
Provence des bouquets de mimosas pour
corolle et tout le long
mon rôle n'est pas ici Paris je ne danse
pas les près de Saint-Germain sont
noires de mouton
[Musique]
le quartier avec des petits piquets où
je me sens malade aveugle de tout péché
rien qu'un département le Var et la
Provence des bouquets de mimosas pour
corolle et Toulon
mon rôle n'est pas ici Paris je ne danse
pas les frères Saint-Germain sont noirs
de moutons
du peuple le quartier avec des petits
piquets je me sens malade aveugle de
tout péché
je viens de loin briser ma solitude
chercher des habitudes trouvées l'amour
[Musique]
je crois que c'est réussi avant tout
réussir soit pour soi
réussir soi-même je crois que c'est
beaucoup plus important
c'est faire vraiment ce qui vous amuse
et pratiquement uniquement ce qui vous
amusait non pas tout tout ce qu'on est
obligé de faire dans ce métier pour
vaguement gagner ce gagné son aide le
croûte
ce serait également joué un rôle qui
m'amuserait un rôle comique
un rôle comique chanter c'est ce que je
préférerais
[Musique]
je suis
intellectuel
[Musique]
André Malraux
que je suis en rébus pour la paix comme
vulgus c'est faux
j'ai toute simple
je me coiffe intellectuel
[Musique]
je regarde la planète
à travers mon jean
[Musique]
derrière façon
chopinoa
[Musique]
je fréquente le même la voix
de Beauvoir c'est faux
[Musique]
dans les coups en l'état je suis une
jeune femme
purifiée
[Musique]
là-bas le carreau
on dit que je vais les voir au meeting
du soir dans ma superbe Jaguar c'est
vrai
[Musique]
de l'amour
mais le style
[Musique]
dans la paume
de cerveau
on dit que mon beau maçon aime les
femmes qui ont l'esprit jusqu'au talon
c'est faux
c'est un Américain qui l'intéresse
et je souffre
politiquement son temps
[Musique]